hmm welcome to this video playing Ross
yeah if not played this guy before him
the five-minute porn is he and let's see
what I can get going yeah my rating
really has taken a slump in the recent
games didn't play well in the last
session and I also lost my warm-up game
pretty miserably yeah after initially
out playing the guy I really played
badly so let's see what what happens
here taking on c4 and going for gras
Arvin what is this know why I draw no
idea why it's just just a normal kind of
position here so let's see how to play
here probably just castles looks normal
so it was a 6cm be 45 is an interesting
way to play I'm going from going for
that trying to exploit my better
development here and possibly after a 59
moves Bishop g5 is good over to d3 now
ready for five let's see if he goes
Bishop e7 or yeah probably
I can even consider Bishop g5 after
Bishop e7 intending to play a five it's
not a bad idea
but if I've also is good yeah I don't
know what is he doing not I'm sorry
Bishop e7 looks very normal have some
doubts about other moves I don't know
but what else is there ok so this one
yeah Bishop g5 to provoke f6 I don't
know if this is a good idea but probably
it is like f6 Bishop e3 I'm immediately
threatening to trap the night with G
Foreman so G for now is a pretty big big
idea ok I can play both actually Queen
takes and pawn takes pawn takes is
interesting because it opens up there
far but ok let's not be too
sophisticated here wyd will have an
advantage no matter what so playing
quickly certainly make some sense yes to
play some awkward looking move now
either e5 which allows 95 that looks
really bad or g6 to give his knights on
retreat square maybe g5 but also this
doesn't look like like the right way to
play yeah okay so I have 95 now i also
have a 4 which is also interesting yeah
i think this is a good idea probably
fighting for the c-4 square
yeah assuming he goes before but then I
have 95 double attacking a porn and the
Queen already quite a tricky thing okay
so he's giving up a pawn going to going
to grab him it's giving away the d5 pawn
yeah maybe that was necessary i'm
ninety-five was a big problem I could
have played 94 before I went there for
maybe that was even the best tribe first
95 let his Queen move and then go away
for maybe that was even better okay this
is this is a very nice position now but
still
yeah this is just a pawn for basically
nothing hmm not exactly a move I
expected but difficult to give him any
advice him so what am i doing like tea I
can take a six then it will take the
three my cannot take b5 probably the
check it's not bad but then he s got
Bishop b6
yeah maybe maybe continue developing him
if he moves the bishop out I can
probably just take a six for a second
pawn things are not not quite sure what
his next move is it really doesn't have
a very clear-cut way to continue yeah
okay this is a maid thread so just
should go g3 probably or Bishop that one
I can also go bishop at one that's not a
bad move yeah let's do that it's not bad
cover g2 like that and get out of the
night here so the night cannot trade
itself I have 95 to try to get rid of
this piece anyway and night h3 is really
just a check not more 95 is a is a key
move i think i should play this now just
get get rid of their for night or this
bishop in both cases it's good i get the
past d pawn on get rid of his strong
night on a form so that cannot be really
bad yeah this is also quite nice chef
but well it really it was already black
resign or a pretty bad yeah it was one
of his first games so this is a
provisional rating yeah we see that in
other in other time controls he's much
much lower not like bad but but just
lower and 24 something was a bit high he
had won the first four games so on this
happens he had those provisional games
yeah I wandered a bit thought he didn't
really play like to for something but ok
so it started by taking this here early
which gives me basically get almost a
free move quite often white but
to move the bishop and then black take
so it gives me a tempo in a way c5 yeah
this is a very simple way to play just
take on c5 of course i can just castle
and I'm okay but I didn't know I think
dc5 was okay I expected actually the
trade like the shack and here white is a
little bit better I simply have the
slightly more active pieces I'm good
better developed but it's not something
that black should be very much afraid of
he can probably hold this position
somehow okay what you went here and now
I kept the Queen's on for a future look
the one with temple but ok he went to
use heaven voluntarily and now here here
now it gets tricky really I I expected
Bishop d7 but it's possible that 'if
I've is already really really
problematic yeah the computer is
actually showing that dish of h7 as a
month I wasn't sure about that yet it
seems that now this is actually just
working him he cannot go to g6 Queen dia
assesses really check tota total
disaster so he has to go back and he is
getting killed yeah so this was a real
problem already nie Dage five-year okay
i provoked f6 him then went back now I'm
threatening g4m trapping the night so he
takes yeah and F takes was interesting
that's not a bad move I mean the ideas
like that let's say like g6 and then e5
but I wasn't sure how good this is I
mean his Bishop is getting some scope
there as well Queen takes us a simpler
move I'm probably the better move yeah i
was expecting g6 now which is a bit ugly
looking but providing some retreat
square e five I thought looks looks
really weird allowing 95 maybe 95
immediately was better that's possible
you know like the Queen now moves and
then I'm going a form which even make
sure that night f4 is not coming it's
probably a little bit better but it's
it's a matter of yeah choosing between
more than one um good line it's a matter
of two clear advantages yeah I could
have played a bit better here even night
a choice given by the engine but this is
still good i really don't see any
problem with that keeping a huge
advantage him and he yeah he blundered
the queen but it's it's still it's very
bad he can take and continue from here
but how is he continuing now I cannot
really develop the night easily taking
them and if he takes on b5 complain that
say Roxy one for Roxy seven and i'm
taking you can take b5 whenever i want
so it's it's essentially still a pawn
whenever I want on b5 entered the deep
pond so there was something better but
it was it was ok ok well thanks for
watching